hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo nos
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
eeuu decidió enviar de vuelta a su país
a los haitianos que cruzaron
irregularmente la frontera y acamparon
bajo un puente en la localidad del río
en texas más de 300 migrantes llegaron a
puerto príncipe en el primer vuelo de
deportación desde la unión americana el
país plantea hasta siete vuelos de
salida diarios que argumenta bajo el
llamado título 42 una norma que permite
una expulsión rápida por cuestiones de
salubridad en tiempos de pandemia el
éxodo hacia el norte también se
concentra en méxico país que estudia
tomar el mismo camino para evacuar a los
miles de haitianos que permanecen
parados en localidades de su frontera
con guatemala
buscaban escapar de la pobreza y el
hambre pero regresaron a puerto
príncipe- en los primeros vuelos de
repatriación que salieron desde estados
unidos y que transportaron a muchos de
los haitianos que acamparon bajo el
puente del río en texas
y salí de haití en busca de un futuro
mejor porque aquí en mi país todos los
jóvenes a pesar de terminar nuestros
estudios no podemos conseguir ningún
trabajo estamos en la calle sin nada
gaste unos 15 mil dólares
estadounidenses para pagar el viaje
desde brasil pasando por méxico hasta
texas podría haber invertido ese dinero
aquí podría incluso haber construido un
gran negocio en las últimas semanas
miles de personas en su mayoría
haitianos cruzaron el río grande desde
méxico para buscar refugio en eeuu en un
momento fueron más de 12.000 personas
las que se refugiaron en campamentos
improvisados bajo el puente agentes de
la patrulla fronteriza en eeuu
informaron que la zona limítrofe en del
río fue bloqueada y miles de personas
expulsadas tres vuelos salieron desde
texas el domingo 19 de septiembre y
planean hasta 7 viajes de expulsión
diarios
en los últimos días hemos trasladado a
unas tres mil 300 personas esperamos que
esa cifra aumente en los próximos días
estamos trabajando con los países de
origen y de tránsito para que acepten
los migrantes que anteriormente residían
en esos países
y es que muchos de los migrantes que
llegaron hasta del río vivieron durante
años en diferentes países de américa del
sur pero ante los obstáculos por
conseguir un estatus legal en esas
naciones y no poder emplearse en
trabajos dignos decidieron volver a
emigrar esta vez hacia el norte del
continente una orden de salud pública
creada durante la pandemia introducida
bajo la administración trump permite la
expulsión de la mayoría de los migrantes
sin la posibilidad de que puedan
solicitar asilo el gobierno de joe biden
mantiene esa norma aunque los menores no
acompañados están exentos y las familias
no estarían siendo expulsadas
pero aunque la decisión de eeuu puede
portar la crisis está lejos de ser
resuelta son miles los que están en
tránsito y viajan por los países de
centroamérica o están esperando en
mexico para poder cruzar esto es lo que
pasa en los países de paso
el caos cientos de esperan poder cruzar
hacia estados unidos las advertencias de
que no los dejarán pasar o de su posible
deportación no les importan y es que no
llegaron hasta aquí para rendirse cuando
los separan una frontera de su destino
que está pasando
mientras tanto en tamaulipas algunos
toman un descanso este centro de
convenciones fue acondicionado como
refugio
wilson caminara hacia la frontera y
denuncia que ha sufrido abusos durante
el viaje caminar a pie corriendo
inmigración se atrae nosotros
a veces ellos o sea a veces no todo el
personal que busque tienen buena gente
buena gente hay persona que mala también
esa estafa nosotros en nuestro país
también dice que tal viene el de ello
también entonces mucho calamidad a
nosotros al sur en la zona de frontera
entre méxico y guatemala unos 40 mil
migrantes deambulan por las calles
tapachula es un callejón sin salida nos
están dando citas no nos van atendiendo
se está maltratando es ahorita que llega
a tomar
vaya con un haitiano com ar me diga
arrepientan a alguna autoridad no tiene
ningún ninguna persona para leen
información es eso o dios significa que
los inmigrantes no tienen valores a
tomar que es una institución que está
aquí para responder a la necesidad de
los inmigrantes no sólo están haciendo
la situación también desborda a los
locales y es una intranquilidad que ya
no ya no podemos
con ella yo no sé a quién es poderme
dirigir verdad que vengan a poner orden
hacia estas personas se les entreguen
los documentos que requieran y pues se
les de pase libre porque pues a mí no no
no me benefician al contrario me afecta
pero la migración en masa hacia el norte
parece no tener una pronta solución en
necoclí zona de frontera entre colombia
y panamá continúa el represamiento y
unos 15 mil migrantes esperan poder
continuar su tránsito hacia eeuu
un día después de las primeras
deportaciones desde eeuu cientos de
haitianos decidieron regresar a mexico
ante el temor de ser enviados hacia su
país no es común que la casa blanca
realice expulsiones repentinas sin
embargo ha tomado medidas extremas en
momentos de picos de la migración hasta
que inmigrantes de france24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
sigan con más información en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]